robert greene is one of the best-selling
authors in history he's wrote in great
books like the 48 laws of power the 50th
law of power mastery and the laws of
human nature in this conversation we go
deep into robert's mind how he thinks
about human nature social media and
where the world is headed i really
enjoyed this conversation with robert
and i hope that you all enjoy it as well
this episode is brought to you by ftx
you can click on the link in the
description to learn more about them
let's get into this episode with robert
and let me know in the comments what you
think about the conversation all right
ladies and gentlemen i've got robert
here with me uh robert one of the key
things in a number of your books and
interviews is nonverbal communication uh
we obviously live in a digital age many
people who listen uh to this podcast uh
they are very excited about uh the
digital world whether it be bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies whether it's uh other
kind of digital products or even things
as kind of forward-looking as the
metaverse whatever that ends up being
how do you see nonverbal communication
playing out in a world where we might
not be able to see each other's real
faces or see body language in the same
way that we could if you and i sat down
at a coffee shop
um you know the great things about the
digital world and as we were talking
before i love the whole podcasting
environment
but there are real dangers in this i
mean if you think about the human animal
as it evolved over the course of
hundreds of thousands of years
a lot of who we are a lot of how our
brain developed is an interpersonal
communication
well before language was written we
learned to pay attention to other people
to their body language to the signals
they gave off and we could read their
behavior i have this belief and other
people have written the same
that our early ancestors before maybe
even before language was invented had
almost telepathic abilities to
understand the thoughts of the people in
their group in their tribe
their very survival depended on these
non-verbal cues that they were picking
up
and so our brains are developed for that
they're developed for learning from a
person
a master for learning how to make a tool
for learning how to play an instrument a
language etc from that person to person
contact and picking up the cues that
aren't verbal and so
so much uh someone has estimated
that 95
of human communication is non-verbal
you're not necessarily conscious of it
but if you thought about it deeply if
you looked at yourself in the course of
a day in the office or wherever you are
you're constantly picking up cues about
people and it's registering either on
the conscious level on the slightly
unconscious level or even unconsciously
you're picking up their energy
their degree of security their
insecurities their weaknesses their
strengths etc you're continually
monitoring them
but the problem is is that this is a
language that has to be learned and
developed it's like a muscle that you
use
and when you spend
a lot of your time in the virtual
digital world
you're lo you're losing that power
you're losing that ability yes you can
pick up cues
like people watching you now can can
read robert's nonverbal behavior and
come up with negative or positive
feedback based on that but it's not the
same as in in person picking up people's
energy picking up the things that you
can't get
virtually on a screen
and so
when you you know back a couple hundred
years ago just put yourself back in that
in those days for instance in the early
19th century
you had no other forms of entertainment
there was no television obviously no
internet the only thing you have is
maybe theater etc
or music the main form of entertainment
was interacting with people with social
interactions that was what you did in
order to to entertain yourself to get
rid of your boredom or whatever and so
you spent most of your time dealing with
people and you became extremely
sensitive to them
and so i tell people
that you're actually damaging something
you're you're learning you're you're
using you're letting a tool that's
extremely valuable in any realm and
business or wherever you're letting it
go to waste by not practicing this by
spending too much time locked in your
phone and you're not like dealing with
people and learning this language and in
the laws of human nature i have a
chapter on nonverbal human communication
and i could have written an entire book
on it and not all books have written on
it but things like posture
tone of voice the way the eyes move how
a fake smile or a real smile whether
people are genuinely interested in you
or they're faking it whether they want
to see you or they don't really want to
see these are all things that you don't
get from people's words but you get from
their nonverbal communication
so your task in the modern world is what
i often say is you have to swim against
the current
and if the current is pushing you to
have less and less interpersonal
reaction interactions you have to try
and do the opposite you have to try and
go out more you have to go out to bars
or clubs or wherever wherever you can
meet people
and actually develop redevelop the skill
that you had probably when you were
three or four years old but is lying
there kind of fallow and need to develop
it
so that's sort of my take on that
as you kind of extrapolate that out
obviously the rise of social media and
technology uh there's many people uh
would argue that's been a net positive
right a company like a facebook or
twitter allows people to share ideas it
allows for people to learn it allows for
families to reconnect or old friends
and then you can kind of go off of the
social media platforms other pieces of
technology that have definitely had a
positive impact but it sounds like
you're making a nuanced argument which
is although there are very many positive
impacts of that technology one of the
downsides or maybe one of the steps
backward for society is that we spend
less time face to face with that human
interaction
is that okay because there's a positive
impact from the technology and and uh
you know not everything is 100
good uh or do you think that actually
society would be better off maybe
without some of the social media
platforms or uh kind of the activities
that people do on their phones every day
well imagine this imagine you didn't
have your access to all these things
that you have
and the human animal is made so that we
need constant uh stimulation our brains
are continually needing things to feed
on to to process
and so if you don't have your phone you
don't have your computer you're left on
your own what are you going to do you're
going to become extremely creative with
what with your time with how you you're
going to find ways to entertain yourself
often in a group situation
and i remember when i was a child
i'm not trying to sound like i'm i'm a
luddite or anything i'm just answering
your question as best i can
but the fact that you know i we had
television and of course that was a big
thing because i grew up i'm so old i
grew up in the 60s and the 70s but um
mostly you had to make up your own games
you had to constantly create things to
keep yourself from being continually
bored and that kind of develops the mind
it develops your imagination in a very
positive way
and i remember back in the early years
of the internet which you know
strangely enough was like some 20 years
ago where it had more of that that kind
of interactive possibilities than it
that have come since then so i remember
for instance
like on amazon something that was really
exciting to me
was i would look for a particular book
and then it would suggest other books
which it still does but it would also
suggest
communities of people that you could
interact with who also were fans of this
book or might be interested in this kind
of subject i thought this was great and
i was actually connecting to people i
even made some friends people who who
are like nietzsche fanatics like i am or
particular forms of philosophy etc
and soon amazon got rid of that because
the um the algorithms something like
that isn't making any money for amazon
and the need to continually generate
profit made it so that
everything was was designed for for
selling things and so
thank you and so um
uh
so you know peop that kind of
interpersonal thing where you could
create a community of like-minded people
and connect
is something that's been degraded over
the years and it's turned into into
something else in a way and
i think people are kind of hungry
for more real human interaction i'm
sensing this
in gen c in young people who are growing
up now that they're a little bit tired
weary of the hours that they're being
sucked into things like instagram which
you know i i use quite a bit i'm at
fault as well i i think i found it i'm
very seductive but i think they're
hungry for something a little more real
a little more experiential a little more
interactive and interpersonal
and i think actually that is the future
combining the immense powers
of the digital world which we all know
and appreciate and love
with something a little more personal
and human where you use this
immense tool
for something where you know okay we now
can create a group and we can get we can
meet people you know
but you know the thing that's
revolutionized my life
to to highlight the positive aspect
is
just in if i have some idea like i'm
researching a story about a particular
man
who there are not many books written
about for my new book
and i can just go on google and put his
name in with like two other words of a
subject that he's interested in and all
these things pop up it's insane it's the
kind of thing that would like a leonardo
the da vinci would have like just gone
crazy over the powers of it are
absolutely immense but it could be used
i think sometimes for better purposes
that's my only point
what is your process for writing
your use of the technology over the
years has obviously changed if i
understand correctly probably in your
mid-30s or so is when you pitched your
first book
you've written seven of them since
you're now working on your eighth what
does that process look like uh today
when you go to write a book
well it's not very sexy i can tell you
that
um
basically
i i have a subject
that obviously you know human nature i'm
writing a book now on the subject that i
call the sublime that i think a lot of
my readers understand because i've
talked a lot about it
and
that part of the process is very
exciting it's like i fling the doors
wide open
and i try and read as many books on the
subject as possible
now back in the day when i started in
the dark ages of the late 1990s i would
literally go to a library if you can
believe it
like we have one really great library in
los angeles at ucla university here
and i would scour the bookshelves and it
was actually really fun and exciting
because
i would i you know like in 48 laws of
power i had an interest in con artists
and charlatan and swindlers which is a
major theme in the 48 laws
and i would go to the show where there
was one book on the great con artist
yellowkid vile who i wrote a lot about
in the 48 laws there'd be all these
other books about
charlatans
and con artists etc and it just would
open up to me it was so exciting
and i obviously i don't go to libraries
now i do a lot of my research on the
internet through amazon through a books
or through other internet searches
and you get some of that quality in the
library but some of the serendipitous
element where you should come up on a
book you would have never thought about
is kind of missing and i wish i had more
of that but i've been doing research for
so many years that i'm kind of i'm
really good at it i kind of know how to
do this
so i i read hundreds of books on a
subject
i i read a book i take notes in the
margins if you saw my books it would
look like i'm insane
i'm writing little notes to myself
little stars next to this underlining
that saying you know [ __ ] you for
something i really hate or whatever
and making you know different colors etc
and then a month later i go back to the
book
and i put it on note cards and i divide
up the each of the things that are in
that book into into themes
and i create maybe 20 or 30 cards for a
book
and then slowly i compile them
in a kind of a shoe box so as you this
part of it is very analog very undigital
i'm afraid
um i put it in a shoe box
and slowly gets bigger and bigger and
bigger it's kind of exciting it's like
some
organic thing that's growing this
monster that's growing and growing and
growing
and then suddenly you've got like 500 a
thousand cards it's almost filling your
shoebox you go all right
fun's over robert now you got to
organize this material
and i go through and i see the themes in
there and i start creating chapters
based on that so
in the laws of human nature i saw
certain basic themes were kind of
emerging from the cards like our
irrationality like narcissism like
short-sightedness like envy and i would
create these chapter headings and i
would slip the cards into them
and then months later i'd have this
to me it's almost like for me it's
exciting it's almost like a work of art
the um suddenly this mass of material
turns into these
definite categories with chapters and
headings and everything and the book is
there and then it frees me up i don't
have to remember
months later that some
person's had this quote
in the 19th century that's exciting it's
there on my card i you know i don't have
to stress my memory system which as you
get older gets weaker and weaker
and so
right now i'm in the process of writing
my book and i'm using all of my note
cards
and um it kind of
tells me what to do now now that i have
all the themes there but i have to leave
this is a lesson i tell people in any
creative endeavor
you have to leave some room for for
discovery for having some fun and
adventure
if i made it too rigid a system where
everything was spelled out before i
wrote the book i personally would get
bored
and if the writer is bored the reader is
going to get bored that's rule number
one of writing anything good
if you're excited
generally you will communicate it to the
reader if you if you learn how to write
some degree
so i have to be excited so i leave
myself some wiggle room i'm still
discovering as i'm writing a chapter i'm
still just coming up with new ideas
and so i'm it's i'm kind of creating it
as i go but it's this kind of organic
weird piece of yeast or whatever that's
growing and growing and growing and i'm
shaping and shaping it
and it's it's exciting but it's also a
lot of hard tedious work involved
when you're reading the books uh in
preparation to write the book or as part
of the research process do you read
books kind of front cover to back cover
and read every word do you skim through
them are you looking just kind of for
themes and then if something catches
your eye you'll dig deeper into it how
do you kind of approach
you have to read so many books to do
this what does that process on a book by
book basis look like
well it's very easy to answer that if
it's a great book
and i'd say maybe 10 to 20 are great
books i might be a little inflating a
little bit
i read every word i'm so excited this is
like what i live for it's like
discovering a gold mine for me i'll read
everything
and a great book will turn into 40 or 50
cards
if i'm reading a mediocre book which is
unfortunately the majority of them
i won't read so deeply i'll kind of skim
i'll go this is crap this is stupid this
is not it here this is irrelevant i just
skip to the relevant parts and it'll
yield maybe 20 cards
and then there's a plethora
of bad books out there which i've wasted
money on
um
and i'll
that's where i'm writing in the notes
god you're an idiot et cetera et cetera
and the margins are even crossing whole
parts of the book out
and then um
you know i'll get maybe three or four
cards out of it and i will really skim
that quickly so it depends on the
quality of the work and the depth of
people's ideas if they're if i sense
it's challenging my mind i have to think
or to understand what they've written
and it's challenging me in a good way
i'll read every word of it but if i feel
like this person knows a hell of a lot
less than me
i and i'm not challenged i'll go i'll go
through pretty quickly
when you're consuming this information
obviously reading books uh somebody's
taken the time they've put their ideas
down they've edited they've tried to
make it as concise and clear as possible
but in this new digital world we have
audio books we have podcasts we have
youtube and many other forms of content
how much of it your research and process
is still rooted in books versus maybe
some of the other forms where you may go
listen to someone on a podcast or watch
a youtube video to do some of the
research
i don't really do research that way i'm
pretty much books and occasionally
articles and and internet things i find
digitally
um but mostly it's through books i'm old
school that way
i'm looking for ideas
you know i'm i'm an idea hunter
um you know people back in the days they
would hunt for various animals i'm
hunting for interesting weird novel
ideas that i think are going to shake
the reader up and really excite them in
a way something they haven't thought
about before
and so
i i don't find if i'm watching a podcast
and you know i watch all like watch like
jordan peterson's podcast or or joe
it goes by so quickly i can't
think about it enough i'll take some
notes
but then um what i need to do if i take
some notes on something that that jordan
peterson has said i have to go find a
book that's about that i can't i have to
read something before me and that's a
weakness of mine
um probably in the future people will be
more used to finding these like great
ideas on the internet but i need to have
it a material thing in front of me i
mean i also use kindle as well but i
need a material thing in front of me
that i can underline and that i can go
back to
and if i were smart and savvy in my 20s
i would figure out how to watch a
youtube video and take little clips and
compile them and then turn that into
some kind of written format but i'm
afraid i'm not i'm not young enough to
be able to figure all that out so i'm
mostly
a book person i'm afraid
you mentioned that you're an idea hunter
and i think that's an interesting
concept tell me more about that and how
you think of hunting for the idea
well you know we live in a world that's
full of so many facts and so much data
it overwhelms you right and overwhelms
me
and i'm not interested in learning a
bunch of facts and things about the
economy about where we're headed about
the war with russia and ukraine i'm
interested in what it means in the
higher level picture
so for instance
in my war book which is kind of a sort
of an important book for me one of my
less popular books but it was very
meaningful for me
i write about grand strategy and the
idea of strategy strategic thinking or
grand strategic thinking is to
continually elevate your mind to not get
mired in the day-to-day things that
people are telling you in the little
battles going on around you what people
are saying on the internet or in the
office but looking for what's behind it
what's the meta idea there what's really
governing these things that are
happening before our eyes kind of like
it's sort of like plato's metaphor in
the cave where you're seeing these
passing shadows and they're not really
real and so a lot of this data and stuff
we're getting isn't connecting to
reality you have to think about it on a
higher level what does this mean who is
connecting the dots
and a lot of times
the great incredibly smart people out
there who are connecting the dogs for me
for instance on various subjects and
when i come upon an article like that in
some great magazine or or online uh
magazine i'm extremely excited and i
take note of that and then
i go through a process where i take
ideas and i try to make them my own i
put my little spin on them i make them
i try and turn them into something
that's more relevant to what i'm writing
about or what i'm thinking about and so
sometimes
so for instance
i'm writing right now about this man
that nobody as i mentioned has heard of
his name is gurjev he's this
armenian russian kind of weird
philosopher mystic
and i read it in his book something
about called
this exercise called self-remembering
i go whoa that's really weird that's
really interesting i've never heard of
that before
it excited me because i'd never heard of
it and it also seemed
like it was
something that was
potentially very interesting for my
readers
an exercise that i can then develop out
of it and so i see a line like that
where i go i've never heard of that
before
and it's linked to something larger
right it's got a higher level
perspective
so um it's like climbing up a mountain
when you're at the bottom of the
mountain you you have no idea what
things are like on the ground you have
no perspective if you go halfway up the
mountain you look down you now have a
kind of a perspective about what's going
on there but you're missing part of the
picture
you get to the top of the mountain and
you have this 360 degree view of
everything you have a complete
perspective and what you thought was
reality halfway down the mountain or at
the bottom
you end up realizing it's false so i'm
looking for people who take me up that
mountain take me to the top of the
mountain and maybe see things that i've
never seen before
so um you know that's some of what i'm
talking about here
what's fascinating to me is you
described yourself as a little bit of
old school and you focus on books for
part of your research uh but i know that
podcast and youtube have played a very
big part in you marketing yourself and
your books not necessarily from a desire
to simply market them uh but that's
where you've had you know hundreds if
not thousands of conversations that's
where you've learned a lot from an
experience standpoint talk a little bit
about the importance of these new forms
of media maybe compared to the
mainstream media
that was available before podcasts or
youtube got popular
well that's that's what that's the
greatest thing for me about the internet
for me personally and i'm extremely in
love with it so as we were talking about
earlier back in the days when i was
starting um in the late 90s you know it
was mainstream media you would go on a
television show like i'd be on the
o'reilly factor or on this business show
i can't even power lunch
with this guy i can't remember on cnbc
um
and it was very impersonal and very not
very pleasant like i remember the first
time i was on live television i thought
i was waiting for to be a guillotined or
something i'm sitting there in the green
room like god damn it the whole world is
a whole country's going to be watching
me live and what if i say something
stupid or what if i've got something
dangling out of my nose how awful is
that i was terrified
and then you're like on the spot you're
facing this person who's like media
trained who's wearing tons of makeup
they've got this kind of weird doll like
expression on their face and they're
interviewing this rapid-fire manner
you're having to be in the moment it's
so inhuman and it's so not what you know
somebody who likes to think and give
detailed answers for it's just a bad fit
it didn't fit me at all
and so
somewhere around
2006 2007 2008 when the whole podcasting
world was just kind of in gestation
really and i remember some of the first
ones you know we would do it on skype
etc
i got really excited
because here instead of some some idiot
on some tv show who's just who's just
like a face who's never read your book
because they just have notes from some
assistant who kind of condenses it into
two pages full of inaccuracies you don't
even have your birth date right etc
here i'm talking to somebody
i can't remember the first guy i
remember but he was really interesting
guy
he was like what would you call a
transhumanist whatever that means i
remembered very well
he was like my first podcast and he like
had read my book
he was asking me question detailed
questions it was clear
that you know maybe he didn't like
everything i said but he had read it wow
what a novel idea somebody's actually
read the book that's interviewing you
and it was like personal you know he
we were looking at each other in the eye
we could i could talk for several
minutes i could answer
i loved it i fell in love with that that
moment and from then on
there's no looking back you know and it
gives the author a degree of control
so i can now reach
hundreds thousands millions of people
around the world and since things like
instagram and tick tock have taken off
in youtube
man the power is just unbelievable so i
can take videos like from this podcast
and others
and i can you know put them on my own
platforms so last in june my wife and i
we were in london
and uh
people this had never happened to me
before people were coming up to me they
actually recognized me in london you
know like security guards at museums etc
and they were very excited they saw my
podcast it opens you up to this
worldwide audience
that is it's just fantastic and
i love every aspect of it and i'm very
grateful that i'm able to have
experienced both worlds because people
who were born nowadays or just starting
out they don't understand how ugly
depressing and demeaning it was back in
the days of mainstream media and people
who only live back in mainstream media
they only had that horrible experience
of feeling like you're you're like being
interrogated on on this live show but i
have kind of bridged the two and i know
there's no going back this is this is a
beautiful ecosystem out there what's
fascinating about this is that i think
in america the cable network
kind of subscriber base is somewhere
between 65 and 75 million people which
seems like a very large number
tens of millions but youtube's monthly
active users globally is over 1.8
billion
and so you compare those two it's just
not even anywhere near the reach and
scale uh both geographically but also
just aggregate audience size that you're
targeting
it's unbelievable and it's it's
exploding now
in the last three or four years it's
kind of taken this exponential growth
with through youtube and instagram and
tick tock
where now you know your little video
clips are reaching as opposed to a
podcast that would reach thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands you're now
reaching millions
maybe even some people billions of
people around the world you know i'm
getting
messages on instagram from people from
india pakistan iran etc we're looking at
these video clips
the sense of power is incredible and you
can almost get a little bit drunk on it
you have to be a little bit careful you
have to realize you have a
responsibility
to kind of
say things that are meaningful and
realistic
and
realize that with this kind of power
comes a degree of responsibility
but it's absolutely insane and if
nobody
living 50 years ago a writer or an
entertainer could ever imagine that they
could have this potential reach for
their product and so um
that's that's probably the as i said a
hundred times it's the best thing
for me personally about the digital age
and i i'm
i'm completely addicted to that part
what we're talking about to some degree
here is a transition or an evolution in
trust right your attention goes where
kind of your trust is and so
now whether i listen to a podcast or i
listen to the mainstream media i'm still
consuming information usually around
ideas current events uh and individuals
and so we can see anecdotally in our
day-to-day time spent that that trust is
shifting we also know from
surveys and various other kind of data
sources that institutions are losing
trust with both people here in america
but also globally how do you think about
that
evolution is that a positive development
is that a negative should we try to
reverse course and drive more trust back
to the institutions or is this a healthy
situation that's kind of unfolding
it's very healthy i mean if the
institutions reflected reality if they
reflected who we are if there was some
kind of connection to our daily lives
then you know maybe we should flow back
to that kind of trust but that's not the
reality that we live in
i've been reading from researching for
my new book
i read a couple of very interesting
books
one of them is called i believe deep
history i can't remember if that's the
exact title
but what he's trying to show is that
because in my new book i'm going a lot
into the neuroscience of the human brain
is that
our brains are basically very chemically
oriented and
we have these kind of hormonal
um impulses and charges and electrical
charges passing through our brain
continually
and
humans since the time beg
has begun
searching for ways to kind of control
the chemical environment of their own
brains
they did that in the past through
ingesting certain drugs which has deep
history among humans going back
thousands of years
they had rituals that they would go
through in which they would challenge
themselves they would almost go near
death and change their own brain
chemistry and have ecstatic experiences
or they had religion
but this element of being able to alter
your own brain chemistry is something
that has been used also for other
purposes by people in power to kind of
create ways of programming you of
programming your thoughts of telling you
what to think how to think what is true
what is real and it's been a very
dangerous thing throughout history it's
sort of the history of dictatorships and
fascists and someone like a hitler or
joseph stalin took that power to an
incredible degree
um and today that kind of negative
suggestibility power that is built into
the way the human brain is and how our
chemistry is so susceptible to being
influenced either actively or passively
the powers are both very positive and
very very negative and very dangerous
and so
there's a reason not to trust a lot of
these platforms you know
things like um
facebook or instagram they're based on
on algorithm algorithms and things that
are manipulating that are manipulating
how you think how you feel they're
programming for you
material content and when they program
it they're literally programming your
mind they're making you think of what
they what they want you to think about
you need to take control of that and you
have the power to control to take
control of that through what you're
saying now you have access to all these
different podcasts to all these
different sources of information
and so you don't have to follow the
large you know institutions and
conglomerates and giant tech
corporations that are trying to program
your world and trying to program how you
think and i'm not trying to sound like
i'm some insane conspiracy theorist
because that's not where i'm coming from
it's it's more like
you're not aware just to what degree
they're feeding you material and that
you're not actually in control of this
process
and so just to this extent that you can
choose what you listen to and you can
have a degree of cynicism and distrust
and go
where is this person talking from is
robert green actually being paid
by some third party that we don't know
about he's trying to tell us something
let me research let me find out if
anthony's show is legitimate or if
there's something behind it do your
research don't be so naive don't be so
trusting i think it's a very very
healthy development in that way
as you think about programming uh or
being misled uh consuming content that's
kind of fed to you whether it's
doom scrolling on the internet
or it is kind of cable network
television
one of the ideas that has become very
popular from folks like elon musk and
many others is this idea of the brain
computer interface kind of the ability
to use computational power embedded into
the brain and augment human intelligence
given that you spent so much time
thinking about human nature and now
you're writing a book about kind of
neuroscience and some of the ways that
the brain actually functions how do you
think through
augmentation of the brain with something
like these brain computer interfaces or
other types of technology that people
may want to at some point incorporate
well it's very interesting i'm actually
writing a chapter on that very subject
right now so it's it's very close to my
mind at this point
um
basically
my idea and you can believe it or not is
that we are actually not realizing
just we're only realizing in our
day-to-day lives a tiny portion of the
power of our brains of human
consciousness
we have so much we have an incredible
potential for so much more
we're essentially
not really using our
what our brains could be doing
and so
i'm looking into various experiments in
ways that people have learned to kind of
open their minds to expand their
thinking process to expand what their
senses take in to expand every to expand
that potential i'm i'm saying that
in my book i'm comparing the human mind
and our experience to this kind of
circle
um this you know a certain dimension
and we live inside that circle and
inside that circle is all the rules and
conventions and ways we're supposed to
behave in ways we're supposed to think
that we consider to be reality and we
consider to be socially acceptable
and that circle can get narrower and
narrower and narrower depending on the
culture and the times that you're living
and right now it can get pretty damn
narrow and so
you want to be pushing you outside of
that circle you want to be having
thoughts that people aren't thinking
about you want to be coming up with
ideas that no one has thought of yet you
want to have experiences that are new
they're expanding because that is what
human destiny is that's why we have this
insane instrument which is human
consciousness it's unbelievable if you
study
the details of the human brain
it'll absolutely astound you it is by
far the most complicated
it it far surpasses what any computer
ever invented or will ever invent the
powers that we have in this one brain
now as far as augmenting it through
technology that would be fantastic the
thing that i
am most emphatic about though is the
difference between active and passive
energy
right so
it's true that ingesting drugs
can give you that expansive experience
and i had that in my early 20s i
admitted i've talked about it before i
experimented a lot with with
psychedelic drugs etc mostly mescaline
and peyote
and that but it's kind of a passive
thing it's sort of something that
happens to you and then you don't know
really what to do with it
but to the degree that you make this
expanding process active where you're
exercising your brain where day in and
day out you're training your senses to
look at the to to see the world
literally in different ways to look at
light and color and shapes and people in
ways you never thought of before
through that exercise it becomes
something that's active that you control
and your mind can slowly expand but if
you're just passively clicking on
something if somebody has programmed for
you a way to kind of do this and you're
not actively engaged in it then i don't
find it as valuable and right now um
so i'm doing a lot of stroke therapy
because i had a stroke four years ago
nearly died from it and it's a very
painful process can't really walk very
well
i do hours of therapy every day
and i've learned that the difference
between active and passive is huge so
they create these devices or these
surgeries or things that they people
promise you will will suddenly reverse
the effects of your stroke and i've
wasted thousands of thousands of dollars
on these things and they're useless but
when they're active when they make you
actually exercise every single day an
hour a day with your foot your arm your
fingers they're powerful they're
incredibly powerful
so you want to make your minds active
and if there are and i've had some of
these technological devices and some of
them are very interesting and
potentially could be great but that's
that's where the to me the difference
lies are they engaging us actively in a
process where we are able to kind of
slowly change how we think slowly change
how we look at the world or are they are
we being fed this material
i don't know if that makes any sense it
makes a ton of sense
you've obviously studied human nature
you studied the way that people interact
communicate both verbally and
non-verbally
you also are now studying the brain
but i find it fascinating some of the
people that you've spent time with that
you've worked with or surrounded
yourself with
one of the individuals that i think
surprised people initially
was 50 cent you even wrote a book with
him uh the 50th law talk a little bit
about why somebody who comes from the
hip-hop world uh and you get together
and write a book what drew you to him or
or why was that uh kind of a friendship
uh right out of the gate that ended up
leading to doing some business together
and writing the book
well i can tell you it was never planned
it was kind of a serendipitous thing
which i'm extremely grateful for
so i didn't write the book intending it
to be something so popular in the
hip-hop world
but when i found out like in the early
2000s that people like jay-z were
starting to quote it i got very very
excited because i've always been someone
who's extremely been attracted to
african-american culture it's been it's
a deep part of me the films and
particularly the music and i have a
particular relationship to hip-hop where
i lived in brooklyn
in the early 80s kind of just when
hip-hop was starting out and i saw it
and saw the roots of it i saw some
performances and i got hooked and i
really loved it it was is amazing so
seeing that connection to the hip-hop
world was very exciting for me much more
exciting than than people on wall street
who were reading the book
and so in around 2005 i believe or 2006
50
contacted me through through an
intermediary and he wanted to meet and i
had no idea why he wanted to me to what
this was for and it was i was actually a
bit nervous because
you know i'm this as you can tell this
nerdy white guy
middle class kid from los angeles
i don't really have the background that
he has he's kind of an intimidating
presence i was a little bit nervous but
i'm very open to new experiences if you
knew anything about me and i'll try
anything new or different or weird so i
flew out to new york
i met him in the back room of a
steakhouse in early i believe 2006 he
was with his entourage and i was by
himself i was by myself
it was like something out of a movie or
like the godfather in this in this
private room in the back of a steakhouse
and um i just remember
the incredible bling that he had he was
with there with his son marquise
and the two of them had these
these diamond bracelets that were just
the bling was just unbelievable i've
never seen anything like never seen
anything like it since
and um
i was also very impressed by him
he wasn't what i expected and i wasn't
what he expected he expected this kind
of old grisly henry kissinger type guy
who knows all about power and i'm not
really like that i'm more friendly and
approachable and he wasn't this
intimidating thug he was actually
very smart very thoughtful very calm and
very friendly
very engaging and i we took to each
other immediately
and one thing i've always i've said on
prior podcasts is
i never have a feeling like i fit into
any world i've had this feeling since i
was a kid like
you know i'm in high school and you're
supposed to be
you know either you're either a football
player or you're you're a nerd going to
university or you're fitting in this
group or that i never fit into any
category and i never felt like
comfortable in this particular group or
that particular group i always was
attracted to people who were very
different from me
so i was interested in in the parts of
my high school the kids who were from
the wrong side of the tracks who were
doing drugs who maybe were even involved
in some kind of semi-criminal things i
was attracted to that dark side right or
to some people who are very different
so to have somebody like this who comes
from a completely opposite world than me
um be interested in me
and maybe we could write a book together
which was sort of what we came out of
that meeting with
it was very exciting because the problem
in america if i get on my soapbox here
for a minute is we live in we live with
these kind of walled cultures you know
there's people in academia there's
people in business there's people in
entertainment there's people in in media
et cetera and they never kind of cross
boundaries and that also includes
different cultures etc
and i'm always interested in actually
the opposite in what i can make
connections so what 50 and i have in
common not what we have that's different
about us
you know it's obvious what we have
different about us but what we have in
common is a way of thinking about the
world that is very strategic
i learned from him that being able to
overcome fear is the source of his power
and i've always been someone who's tried
to experiment with risk
and and getting over any kind of fear
that i had so we connected on this
higher level the i the level of ideas to
go back to where we were talking before
and i thought how exciting to get away
from all the [ __ ] of the categories
of
you know you write a book about this and
you're not supposed to to meet these
kinds of people let's get rid of all
those walls let's put our two brains
together our two lives together and
write a book about something that's very
powerful and timeless which is
the power of overcoming all of your
different fears in life
it was one of the greatest experiences
i've ever been through because for six
months
i was immersed in his world
i went to southside queens where he grew
up i met people that he was dealing
drugs with his oldest friend the house
he grew up in i went to his house in
connecticut which is used to be mike
tyson's house a really strange
house is more like a hotel very
interesting very weird i hung out with
him in new york and all of his
businesses i went to las vegas with him
and went to various meetings and then i
went to a party at floyd mayweather
junior's house with 50 in his entourage
it was a it was like a mad adventure you
know it was fantastic it was one of the
highlights of my life so hopefully the
book that came out of it people
appreciate it because i think it's a
very good book
as i hear that story one of the things
that emily jumps to mind is that so many
people uh from his life uh or kind of
where he came from uh he claims that
they already were implementing some of
the things that he read in the 48 laws
of power
they just didn't have i think he says
the technical definitions of them or the
technical terminology but they were
already naturally doing that which begs
the question how much of kind of the
street culture
that some of the folks from the hip-hop
community come from
was just
nurture versus nature how much is it
they just learned because they saw other
people doing certain things they picked
it up and it was human nature and
naturally they end up in the same place
as you having written the book and
studied it uh versus no there is uh some
innate component to it that uh maybe
isn't so easy to identify until you
really study it and understand uh kind
of how this stuff comes together
well there are two things there's being
a hustler on the streets and having kind
of a feral sense a wild sense of what
people are like and the dangers and
risks involved but the question i always
asked in writing the book is wife was 50
different from the other thousands of
kids that he grew up with why did he
turn into this mega success
whereas a lot of his friends ended up
either dead or in prison or in very low
paid jobs and so you can have street
smarts you can be a hustler
but there's a limit to the game and it's
a limit to the game of life in america
where you know you don't have
opportunities that i had going to
university etc and so you kind of hit a
wall with all of that
and what i've noticed talking with
through years because i've met many
hip-hop artists since 50 i've hung out
with drake
recently i've been friends with gz and
and many others
is that
all the street experiences in the world
will not prepare you
for the dangerous games that go on in
the business world right
so hollywood i experienced firsthand i
worked in it is a very machiavellian
environment
but the music industry is even more
machiavellian so you as a as a musician
as an african-american artist you create
this music that's hugely popular but you
don't own it
some large label
interscope or columbia records owns your
material and they'll discard you in a
minute you know once they're no longer
interested in you your careers your
potential for power are very limited and
so
people in the hip-hop world
in the late 90s a lot of
african-americans were starting to
become managers of their own company
people like chris lighty who started
violator
and
they realized that they had to kind of
think on a new level now all of their
street and hustling intelligence will
not prepare them for this very shark
infested environment they're in where
people will smile they say we love your
work you're fantastic but then behind
closed doors they're stabbing you in
their back they're sabotaging you they
never had to really deal with that
because on the streets
people could be sabotaging backstabbing
but pretty much you knew where people
were coming from and you knew the bad
apples here people were smiling you
never could see who the really dangerous
types were
so reading my book was very helpful for
them so they knew all right always say
less than necessary okay when i go into
a meeting 50 told me that this was the
law that was extremely important for him
you go into a meeting you don't sit
there and talk and blab and say what's
ever in your mind because that makes you
look weak and you're probably gonna say
something stupid
just be in control of yourself just say
uh-huh okay yeah maybe all right i'll
see
and that instantly gives you an aura of
power right so these little kind of
things that i wrote about sort of they
had it in their heads about the street
smarts the hustling game in a very kind
of instinctual way which can be very
powerful
but now this kind of made it on another
level more on something that they could
think and intellectualize and make part
of their own daily awareness and
actually have some practical value on it
so
you know there are i've seen people in
business
who have that kind of hustling mentality
african-american and and white et cetera
and it's it's good it's a very important
skill but it's never enough you need
that to be able to think on a higher
level and to extrapolate certain rules
and laws that govern these different
businesses
it's very obvious what uh 50 learned
from you and how he's able to implement
that and i think he gives you a lot of
credit for
kind of helping him in the business
world what would you say you learned
from him throughout the entire process
is there one or two lessons that you
took away from that entire experience
spending with him kind of going from
parties to business events to his house
where he grew up etc
well as i said we kind of aligned in a
very interesting way but there were
things that i learned so as i said
earlier i'm somebody who always thought
i was kind of fearless
so you know i've done things that are
like looking back on i don't think i'd
ever do again you know when i was 18
years old my friend and i we drove
around the country
completely on our own and had all these
really weird experiences i did every
imaginable drug that you could take i
spent eight my twenties wandering around
europe with a backpack working like 20
different jobs in all these different
cities
i took
tons of risks i like taking risks but
when i'm at 50 i suddenly realized man
robert you're actually a very fearful
person compared to him
he literally
i saw him once
uh and i wrote we wrote about it in the
50th law
is he was he had a a single that was
coming out in in like
a record that was going to drop in
september in a single that was coming
out in august and they were going to
kind of debut
on this radio show in in new york
and then
it got leaked on the internet
and people had heard it before it got
released
and his managers and his team were
freaking out because this was the record
they will be upset the artist that he
did it with would be really upset it's
going to create a mess
they were running around like
you know totally in a panic state
and here he was
completely calm
completely in the moment like a zen
master and he goes
all right i'm not gonna try and imitate
him because i can't but here's what
we're gonna do
listen up they all got very quiet and he
said we're going to make this work for
us and he proceeded he
they were watching me took he took down
the large screen tv from the wall and he
smashed it on the ground while they were
filming this and then he took his phone
and he threw it against the wall and
smashed that as well and then he like
hit the table and did a few other things
that created some damage
and they were all watching why because
it was clearly he was acting he wasn't
angry they knew he wasn't angry he said
now we're going to create this meme on
on the internet that 50 blew up when he
heard this news he was so upset
that heads were going to roll and we're
going to use this to get more and more
intention on the internet because he
understood that you had to be kind of
extreme to get attention and create a
story create something viral and through
that
he would control the process and make
sure that the single would now get
talked about that people are going to
watch it and though even though it
spoiled the roll out it actually made
made it
very controversial people were talking
about it and it made it even more
successful which is what we talk about
in that book called
turning [ __ ] into sugar and i go
i could never do that i wouldn't have
that kind of calmness i would get all
emotional and react and it taught me
that i need to become a little more
a little more detached from my own
emotional responses i need a little more
a little more control of who i am i'd
like to be able to do that in a
stressful situation i was envious of him
i thought because i've been in stressful
situations before
and i find i get caught up in people's
panicky emotions etc and i'm something i
still work on to this day but the
ability to step back
and not get upset and turn a pause
possible negative into something
positive
i thought it was
immensely immensely powerful and i was
very envious i also learned a lot about
him as a seducer
i heard him on the telephone you know i
wrote a book on it called the art of
seduction
and believe it or not i thought i was a
pretty good seducer when i was in my 20s
when i was a young man living in europe
you know
young and excited
um
but man 50 was on another level i heard
him on these phone calls with these
these female celebrities etc
he was so charming so smooth
you know so in the moment
he even seduced my mother you know who
has nothing to do with hip-hop she's
like the polar opposite and so something
about his calm energy
i found immensely powerful and i was
very envious of it i wish
i had it and that calm energy to be
honest with you comes from the fact that
he was shot nine times
from right point-blank range right here
through his side of his head
into his mouth and came this close to
dying
and once you've experienced that
what's going to phase you nothing in
life is going to phase you
so uh that's sort of the source of that
power but i've always wanted to be able
to tap into it myself
that's an amazing story uh the last
thing i want to ask about uh 50 cent is
uh you referenced him as kind of
machiavelli's uh example of a new prince
describe the concept of new prince and
why you think he fits it
well you know you have old princes
people who've kind of inherited
their power in their situation people
who have privilege who come from a
wealthy or well-to-do family they're
sent
to yale harvard the greatest business
schools etc they have this kind of look
on their face they sort of we're talking
about non-verbal communication i can
always pick them out of a crowd yeah
that's that's an old prince that's
somebody who grew up with everything on
their side right
um
and then and and they they're very
limited because they're rooted in the
past they're rooted in their comforts
and their security and they become very
conservative because they want to hold
on to the privileges that they already
have
and the new prince to machiavelli is
somebody who rises up from the lower
classes who rises up without any of
those
those little things that come with
privilege right who has energy he calls
it vir which is the latin word for power
um you know literally related to the
word virile this was this kind of
gendered thing this kind of masculine
energy and this person rises up from the
bottom they're not tied to the past
they're completely in the moment they
see what the old princes can't see that
things are changing the nuke that an
energy is is waiting to be exploited
that their new means of communication
new technologies new ways of acting in
the world and they sweep away all the
[ __ ] and all the privilege that the
old princes have and they create what
machiavelli calls a new order right a
new order a new way of doing things the
old ways and means are gone
this is to him the source of richness
and culture it's the new princes that
rise up from the bottom that kind of
make the soil fertile again things can
grow and culture can change and adapt
well 50 is sort of epitomizes that
and the way he epitomized it is
he didn't come up with all of that
baggage that i'm talking about he's it's
in the early 2000s the world is so
exciting and weird to him he grew up
in the worst circumstances you could
have in america you know his mom
dead when he was at the
age of very early age
uh killed she was a drug dealer raised
by his grandmother no supervision
dealing drugs on the streets at the age
of nine and i went and visited his
neighborhood south side queens and man
it was an eye-opener and it was a lot
worse from the time that he was growing
up in
okay so you know he he rises up in this
world so now he's got all this power
this money and it's like he's in a candy
so this is incredible and he's seeing
things that all the old white guys in
the music industry don't understand he's
seeing that that for an artist
you've got to create
your own business you can't just become
a rap artist because that's that's to
have no power in this world because the
record label or the even the audience
will get rid of you after a couple years
you need to become a business person you
need to start your own clothing like you
need to start your own book like you
need to start merchandise etc he was in
the forefront of that you know deals
with with smart water etc
and he was open to everything and he was
particularly open to what was going on
with new technology he was one of the
first
rappers to really really grab onto the
internet
and create like web spaces internet
spaces to sell his music with on
so that's the power of a new print
they're not tied down
by all of the rituals and traditions of
the old world and they create new new
traditions a new world and so that's why
i called uh
50 a quintessential new prince
yeah it makes so much sense another
person in your life uh that that's
fascinating um that you interacted with
is uh ryan holiday he was an
apprentice for you for a number of years
um talk to me about what did you see in
ryan who's now gone on to have a great
career as an author uh so early on why
spend your time to uh teach him as your
apprentice
well ryan has violated
law number one of of of the 48 laws
never outshine the master he's
completely outshone me i'm now living in
his shadow it's ryan's world excuse me
but um
ryan was like 19 years old if you can
believe it when he first approached me
um back in
2006 i think somewhere like that we had
a lunch a very weird lunch you can
imagine
that that lunch was tucker max and neil
strauss and me and ryan you know that's
a weird mix of people
if i'm remembering correctly and anyway
ryan was very eager
and he was very big fan of my books
and he he wanted to you know see if
there's some kind of something we could
do where he could do research for me
the time i was finishing up my war book
and i was getting ready to do the 50
book
and
i never really had had anybody help me
on my books before
but there was something about him that i
probably sensed at that time hopefully
if i'd give myself credit for something
where i could sense that he was first of
all very smart
that he was very eager and that he had
good character now i have often been
wrong in those judgments before with
people
but for something i detected in mine was
actually correct
and
i said sure i'll try you out
and
because i wasn't totally convinced and i
gave him kind of a test
on the research for the book
and
he did a good job he did it on time
which is important he didn't i gave him
a few days didn't take weeks or months
and
then i read what he had
it was good but it wasn't great
so i gave him criticism i said look this
isn't bad
but really what i you have to think on
this other level you know when i'm
looking for stories from my books they
have to be something that's very
entertaining but also has a lesson
that's kind of a high bar and you were
slightly missing that
and most time you tell people that and
it's been my experience since
they kind of wither up like like an ice
cube in the sun they just kind of melt
and they get all whiny and insecure you
can see it in their body language
they're pretending that they go oh okay
okay you can tell from their nonverbal
communication that they're upset they're
insecure be like criticizing i thought
it was so great
brian was the opposite he was fine he
took it and he actually kind of enjoyed
the criticism you know go wow
this is amazing
i can actually have somebody here or i
can beat up a little bit and he's going
to enjoy it and he's going to take it to
a higher level from that moment on there
was no looking back this guy's going to
work for me and we kind of
he kept learning from the process which
was really important to me in other
words he didn't kind of
take one idea i had about what i told
you about stories and just kind of glom
onto that repeat it which is what i get
with a lot of researchers and assistants
he became creative and he kept thinking
well how can i be more of what robert
wants and how can i listen to him
and you know finding somebody like that
who's intelligent smart he's got good
character
is like finding a piece of gold it's a
rare opportunity in life and i remember
very clearly
um i had a wikipedia page in which there
was some nasty things that were on it
and i said and i don't think i even
asked him i think he just did it on his
own he completely fixed my wikipedia
page and for an old guy like me i got
whoa this guy's like a magician he can
go in there and he can fix a wikipedia
page for me
and at the time i was working at
american apparel i was on the board of
directors for the company
um
because i was kind of friends with the
ceo doug charney
and dove was
complaining about his wikipedia page
and i said i've got the man for you this
guy's gonna fix your wikipedia page he's
like a magician he did it and like me
dove was like totally impressed he hired
ryan ryan became like a marketing
executive at the age of like 22 or so
and quickly rose up in the ranks
at american apparel and so
he's got
a kind of ambition
that's a positive ambition
right a lot of people in this world
particularly young people who are
ambitious
they're very egocentric it's all about
themselves
have an agenda i want to get something
out of this i want credit i want
attention i want people to notice me i'm
in a hurry to make a lot of money and
have power
now ryan is an extremely ambitious
person he was in a hurry to have
success
in his writing and and to make money but
he all he wasn't like this ego driven
person which is very true considering he
wrote a book called ego was the enemy
he could learn he could take criticism
and so you mix ambition
with that kind of character where the
spirit is open
not closed where you want to learn where
you can take criticism where you can
handle stress
and man you're going to rise to the top
and you you combine them with energy and
with somebody who's got a very
interesting mind like he does
you know the sky's the limit he's going
to outshine the master one of these days
and he already has
so ryan's one of the great things that's
happened to me in my life i have to say
that is a fantastic story you spend an
incredible amount of time either as an
advisor a friend or with business
relationships with some of the world's
most successful entrepreneurs investors
musicians celebrities athletes etc what
are some of the takeaways that you've
had from those experiences are there one
or two common traits that you see
in these individuals who have all
reached great degrees of success that
maybe you haven't covered in the books
or things that over the last couple of
years kind of stand out in your mind
well you know it's one thing to sit in
my office by myself reading books about
mostly dead people and then writing
books
you know about them
you know that's easy right
but you imagine being an athlete on a
pro basketball team or entertainer or an
actor or a ceo the stress is much
different it's on a much different level
you're having
you know i'm writing in a book
theoretical stuff you're in the actual
laboratory dealing with mean nasty
egocentric agenda-driven people in real
time not through books with dead people
so i have to be very
admiring of them and i have to be very
forgiving of them as well because they
come to me with problems
right so people don't come to me
full of themselves and going you know
robert you know i'm so great don't
admire me they say
there's a little bit of humility there
like
i [ __ ] up
i hired this person and they're terrible
the manager of this general manager of
this team they're saying all kinds of
nasty things behind my back trying to
ruin my reputation
on the internet i wasn't expecting it i
was naive help me
and so i have to kind of tone it down
and realize
that that is something that i would
definitely be happening to me as well
because it's one thing to talk about
this in a book it's another thing to
have to live this in a day-to-day life
deal with the stress and the pressures
of having that amount of attention and
celebrity
um but the other thing is is that
most people nowadays
have who rise to the top like an elon
musk so they have very good technical
skill
they understand business or finance
or or sports or or whatever their their
business is
but they don't understand people they
have a blind spot right we all have that
blind spot even i do and i've i admit
that i've misjudged people's character
even me who's written books about how to
judge people's character i still make
mistakes
but um
this is their blind spot because they
haven't spent years
observing people like i have they
haven't spent years kind of
seeing what's behind the mask that
people have
and imagine
that you're suddenly somebody who's
extremely powerful and successful in
this world right and you it's almost
overnight
and everyone around you is saying
man 50 that's the best idea you're
fantastic you're wonderful that you know
they're doing all the kind of
sycophantic things that people do in any
kind of inner circle right
and if you're not smart if you don't see
through that it goes to your head it's
like a drug and you go yeah i am great
yeah my ideas are perfect yeah i know
everything yeah it's true that i'm i'm a
genius yeah
okay and then you start losing contact
touch with reality and you start saying
and doing things that actually are
alienating people and you get in trouble
and so
a lot of these times i have to kind of
people bring people back down to earth i
have to kind of help be the critical
voice and say no those ideas aren't very
good actually
you've been listening to the wrong
people they're saying yes yes yes but in
their mind they're going no no no i'm
telling you no no no and it's real i'm
not going to [ __ ] you i'm not going
to feed you what you want to hear a lot
of times people come to me they want to
hear what they already wanted to hear
and i'm not giving it to them and then
most of the time they're grateful
sometimes they go and they run away i
never hear from them again but that's
fine
right but the other thing is
is that what separates
to me a person of power from someone
who's got limitless potential for power
is are they willing to listen are they
willing to change are they willing to
adapt that's what happens with like the
new prince or someone like 50 or someone
like ryan holiday
you don't come to me with preconceived
notions of what's great what's good how
to deal with people how what's said
you're open to some new ideas you're
open to some critical thinking to some
criticism about you
and that is what makes a great leader
you know this is something that comes
strictly from machiavelli himself he
said
a lot of people rise to power based on
one single quality it could be extreme
extreme aggression where they intimidate
everybody it could be
great persuasive powers whether just the
best order in the world have incredible
sensitivity to psychology they get to
the top
because they're the times are right for
that aggressive person or that
persuasive person
and then the times start to change as
they inevitably do
and they keep being aggressive they keep
being soft and persuasive and seductive
and the times change and it doesn't work
anymore and they're destroyed by that
they go from up here to down here it's
an incredible downfall and he says the
person who can adapt who can change
their character who can you could go
from being aggressive to being soft when
it's necessary that is a person of power
who has no limits and so i tell that to
people and hopefully they listen to me
but that's sort of the main takeaways i
have from from my consulting work
it's
a timeless principle of humans are
incredibly adaptable another thing that
you talk about is how individuals
uniqueness is a source of their power
how do you usually talk through with
folks to figure out what their
uniqueness is right uniqueness is
something that obviously each individual
can either pursue a process or somehow
think through to identify what is that
power that they have
is there any tips or tricks that you
have there uh for people listening in
terms of how they can identify what
their uniqueness is
well i wrote a whole book on it and so
it's you know if you give me like four
hours i'll give you the best answer but
trying to condense that down
the first thing you have to realize is
you have to come to the mountain you
have to get down on your hands and knees
and go
being unique being weird being different
is my source of power most people pay
lip service to that or they don't but
they don't really believe it they don't
really understand it
so i try to explain why that is your
source of power okay
and i point out
look at those people who are successful
in the world who you may admire
artists people liking elon musk people
like the 50 cent people like a jc etc
there's only one of a kind
they're different there's nobody else
like them in this world they're truly
weird they're truly unique right
okay they didn't try and become like
everybody else if you become like
everybody else then there's no power in
it right because you've just imitated
what what the trends are there's a
million other people out there like you
on on instagram and social media so why
you
you what makes you different what makes
you weird what makes you strange
is your source of power right it's your
kryptonite etc and so
i explain also why you are you explain
the genetic component how your dna has
marked you as unique and why your
experiences in this world from the age
of two or three and on in your parents
is unique there's nobody else ever in
the history of the world that will be
like you or will ever be like you
so why run away from that running away
from that is cowardly and it's stupid
and it's counterproductive okay
and i drum that into people i drove into
the idea the desire
to mind that uniqueness that's got to be
step number one because if you don't
want it you're never gonna get it right
and you have to want it with a kind of a
desperation
right
so i knew
fortunately for me at a young age that i
wanted to be a writer i couldn't figure
out what i wanted to write but that's
what it was and when people tried to
push me away from that like sometimes my
parents or my peers people early in my
career i get so [ __ ] angry no way man
this is what i'm doing you can go you
can go whatever do whatever you hell you
want to do but i'm going to be a writer
get the hell out of it don't tell me
what to do with my life it's my life
that's because i knew what it was and it
engaged me emotionally so i could put up
with people's criticism i could put up
with the years of failure et cetera
because i was on a mission right i want
other people to have that feeling i
don't want just to be me i want
everybody to have that feeling okay so
you connect emotionally to it that's
step number one if you never go there
forget about it won't happen right
number two is what is that uniqueness
well it's a process
so
you tend to think in these simple terms
you tend to think of
oh i wake up one day
i'm going to be a writer i'm going to
write books i'm going to be
a research scientist in this particular
field i'm going to be a great musician
or veteran that's not how it works it's
a process it's a process of discovery
it's hit and miss you don't wake up one
day and decide this is what i'm going to
do it comes to you
right are you open to it so i never knew
that i would write books like the 48
laws of power that never was my plan
but when the opportunity came to me
and a man asked me for an idea of a book
and this is the idea that i improvised i
was open i was ready i have skill and
this is where my life took off i never
planned it that way so stop thinking
that it's like the simple single idea
that will come to you that you've got to
follow it like the straight line it's an
adventure it's a journey you're on it's
a process
what is that process it's discovering
what you actually love what makes you
different from other people what
attracts you
so if you if you're involved in let's
say math
if you're learning math when you're 10
years old and it doesn't connect with
you
you're kind of half learning you kind of
hate it don't really like it drudge work
you do it at home
but then
there's like sports
baseball or basketball football and man
you're totally in there you're in it 100
you love it
it's there you don't have it's not
tedious to go to practice you like
lifting weights and getting in shape you
like the
the exercises you have to do
that's it things like that are it it's
where your energy is engaged and you
feel connected to it and you feel that
things are easy and to a degree that's
fun and if they're tedious you can push
past it
and so
it doesn't have to be something that's
like basketball which we're not all
gifted for or writing it could be
starting a business being an
entrepreneur and i explained to people
the kind of signs that that show at the
early age in high school and in college
because if you're an entrepreneur
theoretically you really want to be
thinking like that in your early 20s
here are the signs of that when you were
young
you don't like working for other people
you have a rebellious streak
you know people telling you what to do
you think they know it all but don't
they piss you off you're an entrepreneur
in training you've got the dna let's go
with it let's discuss it let's figure
out what kind of entrepreneur you should
be right so there's signs of it there's
signs and i suggest a book that i've
suggested a million times to people on
podcasts called frames of mind by howard
gardner and he tries to get rid to help
you get rid of this idea but the only
kind of intelligence in this world is
intellectual book intelligence which our
culture unfortunately emphasizes far too
much there are other forms of
intelligence there are pattern thinkings
there's um there's like musical thinking
there's sports and kinetic energy
there's abstract visualization he
explains it much better than i'm doing
right now or there's social intelligence
where your intelligence is geared
towards other people
you have one of these frames of mind you
have that inclination that bend for me
it was clearly words and linguistics for
others it'll be something else
you at least have to know which one of
those categories you fit in it's a
process of knowing yourself the source
of all human wisdom right so that you
know what makes you different you know
what you value you know what you're
potentially good at what you're not good
at i also flip the script and i say
let's investigate what you hate
right
so
hating working for other people hating
group office politics which is my
profile
these are all signs right things that
you dislike or you might be the opposite
you might dislike being completely on
your own and being alone you need to be
around other people
you've got to learn you've got to know
who you are what makes you different
once we figure out we have a frame
a general outline of what that could be
what i call your life's task then we
start mapping out a way
to possibly begin this adventure that
i'm talking about this journey and
you know it depends on if you're 22
32 or 42 or even 52. at 52 the journey
is going to be
your options are a lot narrower at 22
the world is totally open so the earlier
you start this process the better and i
talk in my book mastery which i go into
this i talk about
charles darwin the great scientist and
the particular path he took and it
literally was an adventure that took him
to south america where he discovered
what he was actually great at because he
was a very mediocre student in england
his father and his famous family were
very disappointed in him he suddenly
discovered he goes on this grand
adventure to south america that's the
paradigm you're on an adventure you may
not go to south america but it's an
adventure it's a journey you're going to
discover things about yourself about
other people about what you love about
what you hate
but it's got to be exciting and you got
to want it and you have to realize that
this is the source of your power so
that's
that's my ten minute version of the
four-hour version i should be using
that that's incredible the last question
that i have for you uh is around
morality and uh you've written a number
of different books uh many of them
documenting your understanding
or kind of the product of your research
as to how human nature works how the
laws of power work and many others
if we look at something like the laws of
power
there are
things like selective honesty keeping
others in suspended terror or posing as
a friend while working as a spy uh and i
always think about um
morality is this weird question because
most people can't uh explicitly define
it in a math or science uh kind of
confine uh it is very much your morality
versus somebody else's morality may be
different and so how do you think about
the intersection of something that is
much more qualitative than quantitative
but still overlays with some of these
concepts do you think about that at all
or is it more so hey i'm documenting uh
human nature and uh you know that's for
somebody else to judge you know what's
moral what's not what's the context of
each individual situation
well in the 48 laws of power
is it's a book that i call is basically
amoral
and you can read that word wrong it's
not immoral it's amoral and i'm saying
power can be used for good things and
clearly we have examples of that like a
gandhi or a martin luther king or
abraham lincoln and power could be used
for awful mean horrible things and there
are plenty of examples in history of
that so power is neutral it's like an
instrument that you pick up like a knife
that knife could be used for carving
something out of wood something
beautiful or be used for killing people
so
power isn't inherently evil it's not
inherently good either it's how you use
it right and my idea in the 48 laws
power my version of morality was
here's this knowledge
that's kind of kept as a secret
about about how to succeed in this world
it's something that elites and people in
power have known but have never wanted
to share
and it irritated and frustrated me that
that these kind of laws that i
observed in hollywood for instance
were not were being it was like we were
living in this fairy tale like people
would pretend
that this hollywood director producer
was all about doing great things good
things noble things liberal values
whereas in truth they were power hungry
and they would do maneuvers that were
extremely
bad or even downright evil right
and i personally was on the other end of
it
oftentimes or i'd witness it i would be
the victim of it and i was naive
and i'm going
naivete and stupidity in this world
could cause more damage than anything
else that more people in this world
suffer from their naivete
and so i wrote that book
with a bit of irony involved because you
mentioned these chapters that on the
surface are actually downright
diabolical i don't deny and you even
left out the worst one of all crush your
enemy totally the one everybody loves to
quote
um but
a lot of it is
keep your eyes open this is what the
world is like don't be so naive don't go
bumbling into the work world in your 20s
thinking it's all about people
cooperating and loving each other and
being wonderful and just having a group
hug that's not the reality you're going
to get in trouble people are going to
crush you they're going to get you to do
the work and they're going to take the
credit they're going to be selectively
honest with you they're going to pose as
a friend and work as a spy open your eye
eyes don't be so damn naive now
occasionally a dark soul in this world
will come to my book and will use it for
those nefarious purposes
and i could be wrong i could be
deluding myself but i always believe
those people don't need the 48 laws of
power it's in their dna they're already
sharks they know maybe the book
clarifies a little bit for them and i
feel sorry about that but i wrote the
book basically to open the doors up and
let everybody see this knowledge see
this is how people in power
operate but in the laws of human nature
i do take a slightly
more different spin on it a little bit
and i
say the source for me
of true someone who's truly good if you
want to use that word which is not fine
happy with content
is their degree of self-awareness
so the people who are the most evil the
most dark the most sinister in this
world are those who think that they are
so good and so righteous and so full of
conviction
and they don't realize that they're
actually the opposite they're full of
this dark energy but their idea that
they're so
convinced of their their rightness is
actually making them do awful awful
things and hurting people they have no
self-awareness they think they're angels
and they're not they're actually devils
in disguise and so
you want to be aware you want to be
aware that you have dark tendencies
you want to be aware that you
are not different from the billions of
humans who have ever lived you have envy
envy is deeply embedded in human nature
come to terms with it look at yourself
and try to transform your envy into
something better and i give tips on that
in the book
try and understand that you are
irrational that you are letting your
emotions get the better of you that you
your convictions your ideas of rightness
is actually your emotions telling you
what's right you have confirmation bias
et cetera et cetera you are not rational
come to terms with that become rational
if you think that you're that you're so
uh
giving and interest in other people but
you're actually very self-absorbed we
all have a touch of narcissist in us
some people are worse than others
clearly but you have a touch of it in it
look at that narcissism that
self-absorption and transform it into
into loving other people to empathy on
and on and on i go i go with aggression
look at your own aggression look at your
own shadow your own dark side look at
your
uh um sorry
your own kind of um purposeless your
aimlessness in life how you're not
really clear about what you what you
want to do look at your tendencies for
feeling grandiose about the world you're
conformity you're a conformist you think
you're such a hot individual but
actually you're just following all the
trends if you're not aware that you have
these tendencies you cannot begin to
change yourself you were not born a
perfect angelic creature it's a work
in in
progress you have to work on yourself
and the only way you can reach that goal
is by being aware of who you are and by
being aware of who you are being aware
that you have
some perhaps all of these negative
qualities
you can begin to work on them and change
them and turn that around and become a
truly good person in this world so
that's sort of my more later older take
on the subject if you will
robert i really enjoy this conversation
what what do you want your legacy to be
when it's all said and done
what do you hope that people when they
think of robert greene they say
what well that you know hopefully uh
years after i'm dead
um
books are still being read and so i've
made my books in that in that vein i
don't make my books
timely in other words i'm not sitting
here in my books writing about events in
2022 because by 2029 the world be so
different people will be laughing at
what robert said about the year 2022. i
kind of create this times vision of what
i think is going on human nature going
back
hundreds of thousands of years
so i want my legacy to be
it's the year 2075.
robert's been dead and buried for 30 40
years whatever it is
i'm 23 years old i pick up the 48 miles
per hour wow this is true this is
relevant
that's to me the ultimate form of power
i could have and if that's my legacy
that's fantastic because what it'll mean
is i touched upon something real
because there's so much [ __ ] in this
world there's so many books written
there's so many people bloviating and
filling the air with all their bad ideas
and stupid ideas and there's so much of
it and i get so tired of it and maybe
i'm part of it i don't know i hope not
but i can't be 100 certain
but if somebody says
now this is something that kind of gets
into the reality of something it's like
a knife that goes cuts into my gut
it's not [ __ ] it's not hot air
there's something real
and it opens my eyes and it changes how
i think
if if i have that effect 50 100
200 years from now
and that's my legacy
i'll be the happiest dead man in the
world you know that won't that word
won't have any meaning anymore but
thinking about that
is my mission in life and it kind of
informs how i write a book so i hope
that is sort of my my legacy that i had
touched upon something very real and it
stays relevant a hundred years from now
that's so good where can we send people
to find you on the internet or find any
of the seven books that you've written
in the eighth one on the way
um well the eighth one isn't out there
yet so give me a little bit of time it's
into here right now
um
but i have this very ancient
website
goes back hundreds of years it's called
power
seduction and war.com the and is spelled
out
so powerseductionandboard.com
there was a website we started back in
like 2003 or four
um and there you'll find links to my
other books the 50th law of mastery
human nature and my new book the daily
laws which is kind of similar to ryan
holliday's daily stoic if you know that
book
anyway um you find links to all that you
find links to my blogs that i used to
write back in the day when people wrote
blogs you know 13 years ago or something
and then you'll find links to my
instagram tick talk
twitter
uh youtube everything all the other
things that you possibly might be
interested in so and then there's even
an email address
to write to me
um i get a lot of emails i have to say
and i do try and read all of them
just don't be upset
they're pissed off if i don't respond
because it's hard for me sometimes i
also can't type now so i still have a
left hand that's kind of dead
so please
you know be be a little uh patient with
me
um but
that's probably the best side
side for reaching me
awesome well robert thank you so much
for your time uh i've learned a ton uh i
think i speak for many many people i've
learned a ton from your books i've
learned a ton from this conversation and
uh
just keep doing what you're doing you
are a uh an absolute treasure of
information and i think people really
enjoy
the time that you spend writing the
books and also speaking in conversations
like this so
anyone who has not read
frankly all of the books
but but specifically i think 48 laws of
power
or the laws of human nature highly
suggest going and checking those out
and follow robert online and we will
definitely do this again in the future
when you come out with your eighth book
it will quickly make its way from your
brain to the uh to the paper and then
published i have no doubt i hope so i
hope so that's my font swish right now
all right we'll talk soon thanks so much
thank you so much for anthony i really
enjoyed it it was great
i hope that you enjoyed that
conversation with robert i learned a ton
it was not only entertaining and
informative but it actually made me more
inspired thinking deeply about where
humans came from where we are headed and
what exactly it means to be human today
this episode was brought to you by ftx
they have really cheap fees when it
comes to buying bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies sometimes as much as 85
cheaper than their competitors they also
have digital stock trading where you can
go and buy stocks with no transaction
fees and no payment for order flow you
get best pricing if you want to buy
stocks or cryptocurrencies head on over
and check out ftx you can click on the
link in the description to learn more
and let me know again in the comments
what you thought about this conversation
with robert and what it made you think
more critically about we'll see you for
the next conversation i hope that you're
enjoying these